Hollywood can never be totally sure what
audiences will like and with every mega
hit and critical darling there come a
few more shows doomed to a quick
cancellation according to the critics
bees are the worst shows to hit
broadcast TV cable and streaming
services in 2019 network TVs biggest
breakout hit over the last three years
or so is unquestionably this is us NBC's
sprawling time-jumping touching family
tearjerker as that formula has proven
successful other similar shows have hit
the airwaves including NBC's owned the
village rather than focus on a family
it's an attempt at a poignant
heartwarming and emotionally devastating
show about the diverse residents of a
Brooklyn apartment building it's about
how everyone's lives interact in ways
both subtle and profound and feel
specifically designed to get audiences
to cry dustin roles of pudgy besaid the
village has no interest in being a
decent series it's only interest is in
using emotional manipulation to Gaslight
its viewers into believing that the
village is trying to say something
profound about the human condition more
than 15 years after the release of bad
boys to the franchise returned to life
with a made-for-tv spin-off starring
Gabrielle Union and Jessica Alba they
play an LAPD detective team who are get
this very different personality wise in
short LA's finest embraces a formula
that's been used countless times before
in movies and TV critics were savage
finding the end results ordinary
outdated and unnecessary then Travers of
indieWIRE criticized the standard
storytelling in his review everyone can
find another show exactly like this one
on Fox or other broadcast networks USA
and other cable outlets and even
streaming services don't make me shoot
you because
not missing family book club after
American Idol became a top rated pop
culture juggernaut in the early 2000s
talent shows flooded TV in 2019 CBS used
its valuable post Super Bowl programming
slot to launch yet another entry in the
genre the world's best in some ways the
James Corden hosted show is formulaic
and familiar like The Voice and American
Idol performers compete in front of a
panel of celebrities and like America's
Got Talent
acts of every striper welcome not just
singers but in its attempt to flip the
script and get innovative the world's
best goes too far and just winds up
overly complicated in addition to doing
their thing for the judges performers
are rated by up to 50 experts from 38
geographic regions purporting to be
experts in different forms of
entertainment then all the various
musicians comedians karate masters etc
compete against each other for the title
of the world's best overall new talent
Caroline franca writing at variety wrote
so very much of the show boils down to
the show explaining itself and
stretching out the judging which mostly
just consists of the panelists gushing
and gasping in awe what if Netflix made
a TV show that played like a cheesy 90
style erotic thriller and what if they
got an Academy award-winning actress to
star in it
the answer to these questions is what if
a steamy primetime soap from Netflix
about a high-powered and glamorous
Silicon Valley investor played by Renee
Zellweger in between her time spent
screaming her frustrations into a
stuffed animal and practicing archery on
human targets she helps out Lisa an
idealistic young head of a biotech
company in exchange for a night with the
woman's husband Sean the whole thing is
such an inscrutable mess that David Opie
of Digital Spy wrote there's a strong
chance that the team behind what if know
exactly what they're doing deliberately
setting out to make something that's
intrinsically bad Katee Sackhoff the
breakout star of the classic 2000s
reboot of Battlestar Galactica makes her
triumphant return to sci-fi television
with another life a tense Netflix drama
about a spaceship full of humans on its
way to make first contact with aliens
unfortunately for Galactica fans another
life is not quite the worthy follow-up
they wanted
this ambitious show is part workplace
drama a starship commander Niko
Breckenridge looks after a craft headed
to a faraway alien planet which sent a
giant creepy crystal to earth giving her
plenty of Duff is her number two Ian the
now demoted former captain of that very
ship awkward meanwhile her husband back
on earth is the only man who can crack
the code of the giant creepy crystal
there's a lot going on with another life
but according to Alex McClay V of the AV
Club it doesn't all work another life is
an unwieldy mashup of a rival and any
number of Space Odyssey adventure
serials and struggles to maintain
clarity or depth with either half of its
bifurcated storyline
while this CW summer science fiction
series shares the name with another
famous science fiction property Pandora
actually takes place primarily on earth
nevertheless it cribs heavily from
plenty of other popular sci-fi pandora
is a Star Trek ask series set at the
space travel training ground of
Starfleet Academy in everything but name
it begins in $21.99 on a Tatooine like
space world called new Portland where a
college aged woman named Jax is the only
survivor of a devastating attack so she
shipped off to fleet training academy on
earth where she'll study under the
tutelage of her uncle alongside a number
of familiar sci-fi character archetypes
all the while Jack's may have a special
secret which may affect the very future
of humankind lightweight and exceedingly
familiar can be fine especially for a
summer TV show but Pandora doesn't quite
strike that tone Beth elder Ken of io9
was exceedingly harsh in her review I
watch a lot of TV pilots for work
including ones for shows that never make
it to air and Pandora's is quite
possibly one of the worst I've seen in
years
I'm not sure we're completely getting
off on the right foot here are we well
it appears are not the only one whose
perceptive then check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]